PAUL: 68 meters.
DAVE: Okay.
PAUL: This is the
easy part you know.
MINDY: Ha, exactly.
NARRATOR: Racing for a
million dollar prize,
Team North America,
three co-workers
from Denver,
have just seven hours
to complete a complex,
three-stage climb.
The first pitch
against the lower face,
will allow them to
get their bearings.
Pitch two is a brutal
mid-air vertical ascent
to an overhang.
And finally pitch three, a
battle against exhaustion up a
crevasse to the end of
day waypoint, Tree Ledge,
where they'll be
spending the night.
MINDY: Yeah.
PAUL: How are you feeling?
A little more at ease?
MINDY: A little bit.
Till you start going up.
I'm not good at ledges,
I, I get a little, little
scared on the ledges.
DAVE: Part of me wonders,
should she go first?
You're probably gonna
be the fastest, I don't
feel that matters.
PAUL: A bit like a sandwich.
DAVE: Yeah, let's do a
sandwich, let's do a sandwich.
Paul go for it.
MINDY: I think I wanna
see how this goes.
PAUL: It, it feels
a little awkward.
MINDY: It's a little awkward?
PAUL: Oh, oh my.
DAVE: Nice.
Get in that rhythm.
NARRATOR: The wall ascent
uses clamps and foot stirrups
attached to a fixed rope,
which tighten then relax as
climbers shift their weight
and move upward in small steps,
like a ladder.
It's a technique
known as "jumaring".
PAUL: My foot, ah!
MINDY: You're killing it Paul!
DAVE: This is a
full-on suffer fest.
PAUL: I was a
gymnast for my entire childhood,
leading up and
through college.
I'm a strong, motivated
and gritty competitor.
PAUL: Oh.
Nice.
We made it.
DAVE: Well done Paul!
You may not hear me,
but I'm clapping loudly.
Oh thanks, why don't you send
down some debris on us.
Careful, debris.
NARRATOR: A
passionate climber,
Paul Montague Junior
crushes the first pitch
in just 15 minutes,
building a massive
lead for the team.
PAUL: A big motivator for
me just being out here,
is to show you know,
representation.
Climbing you know,
big mountaineering.
You don't really see a
lot of people of color.
And there should be more.
If some little, you know,
kid out there is flipping
through the TV and,
I'm on the
side of a mountain.
They go wow, like
he, he looks like me,
or maybe I didn't know people
of color did that or whatever.
I think that's,
you know, inspiring.
DAVE: Take your time Paul.
Captioned by Cotter Media Group.